on va savoir un petit peu plus qui vous
êtes on va vous faire un hard et viau
vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment là je
pense vraiment sincèrement je suis en
train de me demander si j'ai eu raison
de venir dans cette émission je pense
que oui pour l'instant quand vous vous
regardez le matin la glace vous dites
quoi
j'aime pas me regarder le matin dans la
glace je déteste ça ils se détestent mon
image je déteste me regarder à la télé
je me déteste me regarder sur un écran
c'est non non je n'aime pas du tout ça
mais je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui font de la télé qui sont comme ça
quand vous étiez petit vous auriez aimé
ressembler à qui avoue pourquoi moi
parce que je regardais déjà la télé
quand avec vous pleurez pour la dernière
fois à je pleure très souvent mais alors
là ça moi c'est vraiment devant devant
un film devant un film bien foutu vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique à part votre pull
mme
vous pouvez vous dire de plus négatif
sur vous je pense que j'ai pas de talent
je pense que je suis un gros bosseur
mais je pense que j'ai aucun talent je
crois que c'est ce que vous voulez dire
que vous n'avez pas de dons mais du
talent oui parce que quand on réussit
c'est quand même du talent vous feriez
quoi s'il ne vous restait que 24 heures
à vivre
l'amour pendant 24 heures un sucès envie
de faire l'amour pendant 24 heures
pourquoi pas autant essayer c'est avec
du viagra et plusieurs personnes voilà
qu'avez-vous fait jean marc morandini
que nous ne sachions pas
c'est pas tout ce qui est ma vie privée
vous ne la connaissez pas et je pense
que c'est mieux comme ça
une bonne oeuvre une bonne action oui
mais ça se dit pas ça en fait
ben moi j'aime pas les gens qui vont à
la télé pour raconter leurs bonnes
oeuvres moi j'en fais mais je les garde
pour moi une mauvaise action plein à
acheter que les chaussures
ma tante
c'est sûrement pas